another takeaway I have is about power
so inksock the totalitarian States wants
only one thing and that is power
is both the means and the end absolute
power
that's what Brian describes and there's
a lot of quotes about this in the
torture part of the book O'Brien says
the real power
the power we have to fight for night and
day is not power over things but power
over men
power is inflicting pain and humiliation
power isn't tearing human Minds to
pieces and putting them together again
in new shapes of your own choosing power
is not a means it is an end one does not
establish a dictatorship in order to
safeguard a revolution
one makes the revolution in order to
establish a dictatorship the object of
persecution is persecution the object of
torture is torture the object of power
is power
this of course is another aspect of
human nature
the will to power
and the tendency of that power to
corrupt
O'Brien says also
the weirdness of the cell is the Vigor
of the organism
through the torture of the individual
the breaking of the individual through
the death of the individual that doesn't
exist according to the history
all of that doesn't matter
what matters is the organism and um
there's been a lot of brilliant comments
throughout social media and on Reddit I
just want to highlight something about
this because I had the exact same
feeling as I was this time uh rereading
it there's a comment from a Reddit user
whose name is a brave sky 6764.
uh he said the conversation between Lex
and Michael Levin
who is a uh a brilliant
uh biologist engineer uh came to mind
when O'Brien made an analogy to an
organism which survives even as the
individual cells pass away
and the great purges are analogous to
The Cutting of a fingernail
if you see society as an organism
and uh which I think is the way a
totalitarian state
sees it
then the destruction of a large
percentage of that Society the murder
the torture all kinds of atrocities and
genocide become justifiable as long as
the organism flourishes
and um
that's how you get to
the ideas that Stalin had it's okay to
break a few eggs to make an omelet
this devaluation
of a human being
as of fundamental importance in a
society
foreign that's a slippery slope into
atrocities
it's not just deeply unethical from our
understanding of morals and ethics
it is also very unproductive it destroys
the human Spirit and the human spirit is
essential for a building of a Great
Society of constant progress I think
that's also one of the other messages of
the book is about Utopia that
totalitarianism results when you chase
perfection
when you chase when you present this
idea of utopia
there is no Utopia there is no perfect
Society I think at least for me that's
takeaway I think the optimal state of
being for an individual and for a state
is a constant
constant turnover constant change in in
the case of a state it's a constant
turnover of leaders of ideas and always
hopefully in the long term making
progress uh towards a better uh a better
world
but it's always going to be messy
um
Perfection only exists in a uh
oppressive state
Perfection only exists when you remove
the basic Humanity of the individuals
that make up that state when you destroy
the the human Spirit or do you when you
suppress and you destroy all the
freedoms because freedom is going to be
messy it's going to be very chaotic but
that freedom ultimately is at least in
the long Arc of history is going to
create progress
so yes as the the redditor Braves guy
67-64 says that does actually give you a
perspective of a biological system where
it's
a bunch of living organisms each one of
us are made up of a bunch of living
organisms and we take that for granted
of all the atrocities that are happening
there and we don't seem to give a damn I
think that's a really good metaphor for
us to help if if you want to put
yourself in the mind of the inner party
of Big Brother of the people that are in
power in those uh situations I think a
lot of them if most of them if not all
of them see themselves as doing good for
the world is doing good for the society
and they're able to justify that the way
we justify the murder of the different
cells in our body you don't even think
of them as worthy of consideration you
don't think of them as as living beings
of having the same value as you and
that's one of the really powerful ideas
that the founding of the United States
that all men are created equal but
there's an equal Worth to a human being
no matter who that human being is that
idea at the very least as flawed as it's
implemented patients have been is a
really really powerful idea and it's a
non-trivial idea and that idea resists
the drug of totalitarianism the drug of
power
I do believe that on the topic of power
and politics
that 1984 as I've mentioned has been
I would say misused by political
ideologues I've seen it for example on
conservatives in the United States have
used
1984 to call left-wing policies
orwellian
I think that's an overstatement of
course used for dramatic effect but it
should
be at least said that Orwell was the
Democratic Socialist
1984 is not a criticism of socialism
it's a criticism of totalitarianism and
I think the point is a warning against
totalitarianism in all forms
that all political ideologists can
succumb to the Allure of power and be
corrupted by it
and I think people on the left in the
United States and people on the right
can both be corrupted by power
so this kind of one way
uh criticism of left-wing policies as
orwellian is a is a very kind of
convenient shorthand but the reality is
all
men and politicians are capable of
um
creating an orwellian world
and I think one of the things that is
highlighted in the book very well I
would say
if I interpret it correctly is the
hypocrisy of Winston when O'Brien asks
Winston what he's willing to do to
overthrow the party what he's willing to
do for the Brotherhood
Winston admits that he is willing to do
atrocities he's willing to do evil onto
children uh unto anybody murder anything
and I think this is a really powerful
illustration that both the totalitarian
and the blind immoral resistance
Rebellion against the totalitarian state
can both be evil
and I think that's where I return to
love is the thing that carries hope for
a world Beyond this battle this very
important battle for freedom but you
have to have that otherwise it's the
orwellian state and the resistance to
orwellian State can both destroy basic
human rights and freedoms I think sort
of in the character of Winston
that's Illustrated well